[inaudible]
oh,
can I have everybody's attention please?
All right.
So first of all,
thank everybody for coming.
I really appreciate seeing all of your
faces here.
It makes me happy and it's kind of a
sign that we're in the process of
reclaiming sanity on our campus that you
guys all showed up to this.
So thank you.
Thank you.
[inaudible].
I'm just going to lay some quick ground
rules for the event.
Um,
so first of all,
I want to thank Senator Frist,
all the study of Liberal Democracy
Leadership Institute and Undergrad
Theory Association
for all their support.
Uh,
after this I'm going to give the mic
over to professor offer Manco and he's
going to announce Dr. Peterson.
Uh,
photography is allowed but no flash
photography please.
Uh,
no signs are allowed besides a regular
sheet of paper.
Um,
Peterson is going to speak until 8:00 PM
after which we will have a short q and a
until eight 30 and everybody's going to
line up on this side.
I will be holding the microphone.
Actually,
we might not be able to use a microphone
since we only have one.
Um,
okay.
We should have a microphone for
questions starting at eight.
I'll have you all line up down here and
uh,
we will be over at about eight 30 and
after the q and a event,
you guys are all free to leave.
So thank you very much.
Here's professor over Minko
[inaudible].
Good evening
[inaudible] and welcome to our talk
today,
which is called political indoctrination
on campus.
I am Richard Ever Manco associate
professor of political science and
co-director with John Sharpless.
Distinguish mental gentlemen right here
from the history department.
We are the CO directors of the Center
for the study of Liberal Democracy,
the center along with uh,
the young Americans for liberty and the
undergraduate political theory
association organized this lecture
today.
If you'd like to be in the loop
regarding other events,
you can look us up on the inner tubes.
Um,
and like I said,
our talk today is called political
indoctrination on campus.
And I'm grateful to welcome Dr. Jordan
Peterson as our speaker this evening.
Dr. Peterson is professor of psychology
and clinical psychologists from Toronto,
Canada.
He cut his teeth as a professor of
psychology at Harvard University and now
as a professor at the University of
Toronto where hopefully he enjoys the
full protection of a robust tenure
tenure policy.
He's the author of two books,
maps of meaning,
which is on my nightstand right now,
and 12 rules for life,
an antidote to chaos.
Dr. Peterson is also the author or
coauthor of over 100 scientific articles
on issues such as alcoholism,
aggression in the neurology of political
consciousness.
As I understand the titles,
because I didn't read 100 articles in
2013 Dr. Peterson began recording his
lectures,
uh,
personality and its transformations,
maps of meaning,
the architecture of belief and uploading
them to youtube,
which had been very popular.
I will admit publicly that I listened to
many of his podcasts this past summer
while on long training runs.
They don't do much for pace,
but they keep you going for a long time.
Talk to Peterson made something of a
public splash in 2016 when he made a
couple of youtube videos criticizing
Canada's bill.
See 16 which adds gender expression and
identity as a protected class under the
Canadian Human Rights Act.
Dr. Peterson argued that a person can be
prosecuted for refusing to use preferred
pronouns.
A similar law has recently been passed
in California,
which of course raises the issue of
forced speech and the first amendment.
After these videos,
a Dr. Peterson acquired some notoriety.
His Youtube channel has gathered more
than 450,000 subscribers and his videos
have received more than 25 million
views.
As of October,
2017 his classroom lectures on mythology
were turned into a wildly popular 13
part TV series on TV Ontario.
Dr. Peterson also has a biblical lecture
series on Tuesday evenings,
which are almost always sold out and if
any reason to move back to Toronto for
me,
that would be one of them.
Finally,
I learned that like me,
Dr. Peterson hails from Alberta,
I assume he's a right thinking man and
Dustin Edmonton Oilers Fan,
ladies and gentlemen,
Dr. Peterson
[inaudible].
Okay.
Thank you very much for inviting me.
Can you hear me at the back?
Yeah,
that's good.
All right,
well we might as well get right into
this.
So I want to go as deeply underneath the
problem as I can possibly manage
tonight.
So I'm going to marry some of my
ideas about what you might describe as
the grammatical structure of belief with
some more overtly political analysis,
concentrating on what actually what
constitutes ideology because w one of
the things that I've been trying to
figure out,
and I guess this is
part of my attempt to wrestle with some
of the actual problems that the
postmodernist pose because I don't mean
as people or as thinkers,
I mean conceptually because you always
have to give the devil his due so to
speak.
And there are elements of postmodern
thought like the idea that there's an
infinite number of interpretations for
any finite set of facts that actually
happened to be true.
And there are,
they're quite problematic and it's,
it's for good reasons as well as bad
reasons that postmodernism has become
such a dominant strain of thought.
And so it's necessary to take it
seriously.
And I've been trying to,
one of the things I've been trying to
figure out is,
is there a reasonable way of
distinguishing a philosophy from an
ideology in the pop?
The postmodernist answer to that is
basically know that it's ideology all
the way down,
like the turtles all the way down there.
You'd never escaped from the,
from the grip of your,
of your viewpoint in some sense.
And,
and there's some truth in that,
but there's not enough truth.
That's the thing.
And one of the hallmarks I would say of
both poss postmodern Andy ideological
thinking is the proclivity to reduce
very complex phenomena to single causes.
But anyways,
so we're going to,
we're going to go underneath things as
far as we possibly can.
So the first thing that I'd like to
point out is,
or like to discuss is the actual problem
that we're,
that we're all trying to solve in some
sense,
including the ideologues who claim to
have the,
let's say,
interests of either the working class or
the were,
or the oppressed upper most in their,
in their imagination,
in their heart or in their intellectual
concerns.
Um,
and there's absolutely no doubt that
there is oppression and,
and that there's no shortage of
suffering in the world.
And I do think that's not only the
fundamental but also the fundamental
reality of the world.
And this is an existential theme.
It was developed at least to some degree
by Martin heidegger.
Heidegger had a concept that he called
thrownness,
which is an interesting,
um,
an interesting idea.
And thrownness is,
is a brief description of the arbitrary
nature of human being or even of being
itself and the arbitrary nature it can
be.
It can be his,
the word he used for that,
which is a German word,
can be translated in other ways.
It can be translated as abandoned or
dereliction or dejection,
which obviously are much harsher words
than mere thrownness thrown.
This is more of a detached term.
But what it means is that it's a
characteristic of human conscious
experience to be underpinned by
arbitrary realities that have nothing to
do in some sense with your choice as a
being.
And so some of the elements of being
thrown are that you're born into certain
time rather than a different time.
That seems like it's an irrational fact.
That's how young would describe it,
Carl Young as it's an irrational fact
because there's no real way of
accounting for it from a,
from a causal perspective,
not,
not subjectively speaking and you're
born a certain race and you're born with
a certain level of intelligence,
let's say.
Although that can be impaired certainly
with enough effort.
Um,
and you're born in a certain culture
with a certain language and at a certain
socioeconomic it has certain
socioeconomic class and with a certain
degree of attractiveness and those are
things that are all handed to you in
some sense they,
they make up the,
in some sense they make up the axiomatic
structure of your being and some of them
are advantageous and others are
disadvantageous and you're stuck with
the end.
That really is a problem partly because
life in and of itself is a problem and a
problem of suffering.
But also because it seems quite evident
that well,
or at least that you could make a strong
case that the,
the talents and catastrophes of life are
by no means equally distributed.
And so in some sense there seems to be
an intrinsic,
we might regard it from the perspective
of the standards of human justice and
perhaps human mercy as well as something
intrinsically unfair,
unjust about the structure of existence
itself.
Now I like the existentialists take on
that because
what the existentialists do is attribute
that inequality and injustice and say
unfairness to the structure of being
itself and pose that as the central
problem of life.
And I find that very realistic.
I like this painting by Van Gogh.
I think it does a very good job of
expressing that.
You know,
he's an old man and he's obviously
sorrowful and you know,
he's not rich as you can tell by his
shoes.
And like it's rough and,
and he's a nexus of,
of oppression and perhaps,
oh,
a nexus of oh oppression in that he may
have served as an oppressor,
but also someone who's suffering,
you know,
pressed as a consequence of the
conditions of his life.
And so then the question might be,
well,
why is life like that?
And that's where and what might be done
about it.
And that's where the differences really
start to arise.
So we can start from the perspective of
the fact that life presents a universal
problem to those of us who are alive and
conscious.
Now
there are various,
what would you call the Metta theories
that account for the existence of this
suffering.
My interpretation of the story of
Genesis essentially,
which in some sense describes the
introduction of suffering into the
world.
Is that what,
what seems to happen in the story of
genesis is that human beings originally
emerge is a mythological representation.
So to deep fictional representation,
that's one way of thinking about it.
Keeping in mind as you might,
that fiction can be more true than
truth,
which is partly why we're so attracted
to it because fiction distills truth and
presents it in a much more concentrated
form than,
than a mere description of everyday
reality.
And in the genesis story,
there's a,
there seems to be an association between
the development of vision and self
consciousness and the awareness of death
and the awareness of good and evil.
Those things happen pretty much at
exactly the same time.
And the consequence of that awareness
of,
um,
uh,
are that self consciousness is a dawning
awareness of vulnerability.
You remember in the story of Genesis
when Adam and eve opened their eyes or
have their eyes opened as a consequence
of falling prey to temptation,
the scales fall from their eyes and they
realize that they're naked and then they
immediately cover themselves up.
And of course,
the question is what does it mean to
realize that you're naked?
And there's a variety of complex quest
answers to that.
One is that,
well,
if you're naked,
common nightmares to be naked in front
of a crowd.
And the reason that that's a nightmare
is because while people don't like to
have their full vulnerability exposed to
the judgmental I of the crowd and for
good reason like everybody has,
um,
what would you say?
It may be inbuilt sense of shame about
their fundamental inadequacy in
relationship to the difficulties of
life.
And so the story of Genesis,
which I think is a foundational story.
Well I don't think it's a foundational
stories.
Obviously a foundational story,
foundational story of Western culture
suggest that it's mankind's knowledge of
its own nature that leads to not only to
suffering but to work.
You know,
because once you realize that you're
vulnerable and that that vulnerability
never really goes away,
you always have to prepare it for the
future.
Because even if you solve the problems
that are right in front of you this
moment,
that doesn't mean that you've solved the
plethora of problems that are likely to
pop up for you tomorrow and next week,
next month,
the next year.
And,
and that in some sense are beyond your
ability to finally solve.
So,
but there's a different viewpoint I
think that comes out of the Marxist
perspective.
And I'm going to talk to you about
Marxism and postmodernism,
both of which I regard as various
strands of the same ideology.
Um,
and as I said,
I'll define why I think are ideological.
And the,
the,
the thing that strikes me so clearly
about the Marxist perspective is that
the finger is always pointed at
inadequate social order as the root
cause of suffering.
And that just seems to me to be,
I don't know,
it's,
it's so naive that it's difficult to
understand why people can possibly fall
for it.
Maybe it's partly because there's some
hope embedded in it,
right?
There's,
there's an idea that,
well,
suffering might be transcended if we
could just organize our societies
properly,
but it seems to me,
number one,
that that's highly unlikely.
A number two,
as Dostoyevsky pointed out,
even if we did organize our society so
that no one had anything to worry about
from a material perspective.
So everyone,
let's say had enough bread and shelter
that we're the kind of insane creatures
that would blow that apart and fragment
that sort of static utopian perfection.
Just so something strange and
interesting might happen.
And I think that's a really,
that's a really devastating critique.
And you know,
the dusty ft formulated that back in the
late 18 hundreds he had thought through
the consequences of communist utopia
before it even manifested itself as a
political force.
And I think put his finger on exactly at
least one of its primary weaknesses.
So you know,
if we were delivered from suffering,
it's not necessarily clear that we would
be happy about that because one of the
things that does characterize human
beings is this intense desire for
experience that transcends the
normative.
You know,
and people will go out and look for
difficult things to do just for the sake
of doing difficult things.
They climb mountains and they engage in
extreme sports and they put their lives
in danger.
And there's no technical reason for
that.
And it doesn't seem like a very
intelligent thing to do from the pure
perspective of self preservation.
But we're certainly cape capable of it.
And the problem,
the Marxist seemed to lay the reason for
suffering at the foot of inadequate
social structure.
And,
but they go farther than that.
They also described the social structure
as it exists.
And this is where the idea of the
patriarchy is derived as far as I'm
concerned,
as something that is necessarily
an upper class or an oppressive class
against the oppressed class and what the
people who fit in those different
categories can vary with classic
Marxism.
It was the rich against the poor,
the poor against the rich,
right?
The bruce was he against the
proletariat.
And that's being transformed,
I would say by the postmodernists using
a fairly self evident sleight of hand
into identity politics where the
oppressed oppressor narrative just takes
different forms according to the
identity that happens to be plugged into
the same mediational structure.
And what seems to happen as a
consequence of that.
And I mean,
there's pretty good data about this with
regards to the Genesis of um,
uh,
intense intergroup conflict.
One of the things that predicts intense
intergroup conflict,
like the conflict in a Robonda and
certainly also happened in Nazi Germany,
is that,
um,
genocidal activities are often marketed
as preemptive strikes against an
oppressor class,
right?
And so that would have been the Jews in
Germany and in,
in Rwanda,
um,
the same narrative emerged.
It's very common to,
to dichotomize this society as oppressor
and oppressed and then for the oppressed
to rise up and take out the so called
oppressors even before anything of any
of any particular violence occurs
because of this enhanced sense of
victimization and the moral high ground
that it seems to provide that logic
being something like if we're being
oppressed and we have every right to
defend ourselves,
so to speak,
even against threats that are only in
some way imaginary.
Now,
I don't want to get too cut and dried
about that because you know,
it certainly is the case that there
isn't a political or economic system in
the entire world that lacks corruption.
And so the idea that this,
the social structure is in part corrupt
enough so that everyone who is embodied
in that social structure doesn't
necessarily have an equal chance to
manifest their gifts.
Say it rise to the top is certainly true
because human beings are completely
incapable of producing perfect social
structures for a variety of reasons.
Our own blindness,
the fact that we inherit structures that
we don't really understand that are all
demanded in band in one way or another.
And so there's always an element of
truth to critical claims that if we just
got our act together better from a
social perspective,
that everything would be more fair.
And just,
but to say that is not too similar
caneously justify the claim that all the
reasons that human beings are suffering
and that life is unfair and unjust is
because the social structure is corrupt
and right.
You gotta think in multivariate terms.
If you have any degree of intelligence
at all and for any complex phenomena,
there's generally a multitude of causes
and they are not easy to differentiate.
I mean that's partly what's social
scientist is do is to take a look at a
complex outcome.
Suffering certainly being one of those,
and to look at the potential
contributors of multitude of factors.
Now it's very difficult cause those
factors are not easy to categorize and
they overlap and so on and so forth.
But you have to be pretty,
what would you say,
motivated and stupid?
I would say both at the same time,
to use a univariate hypothesis,
two to co,
two to account for a complex phenomena.
I don't care what the phenomena is.
And so that's another hallmark of video
logical thinking is that the causal
story collapses into a single dimension.
You see that often in psychopathology to
where you know people who get obsessive
about something can't shake like a
particular idea that possesses them.
Paranoid people are like that.
And people who have eating disorders,
especially anorexia like that is their
entire value structure collapses into
the dimension of thin equals beautiful
and good and it's very rigid and black
and white and it does the Mab solutely
no good.
So now some of the problems with,
with the Marxist perspective seems to be
that um,
victim hood,
that sense of enhanced victim hood tends
to produce an intense sense of
resentment.
And that's a very bad idea because
resentment is a very toxic and violent
emotion.
It's also very ungrateful,
which is one of the things I would
really say about,
especially the radical left student
types,
especially at Ivy League universities.
I mean it's really quite a spectacle to
see people at places like Yale come out
and agitate as a consequence of the
realization of their own oppression when
by any reasonable standard,
current or historical,
they're probably in the top one 100th of
a percent,
perhaps better than that of all the
people who have ever lived anywhere
ever.
And so it really,
it's really,
it's really quite staggering to me that
the top 0.001% can express their
resentment about the top 0.0001% in such
strident terms without noticing that
exactly the same claims of privilege
apply to them by as long as all you have
to do is transform the,
the,
the been in which you're doing the the
privilege comparisons and that becomes
immediately self evident.
And you know,
the fact that as Americans,
let's say hours North American since I'm
a Canadian,
that were staggeringly privileged
compared to the rest of the world is
certainly a consequence of the,
of what you might describe as the
arbitrariness of our political borders.
And so,
but to forget that when you're claiming
a particular brand of oppression for
yourself seems to me to be
very ungrateful at the least.
And certainly motivated,
let's say politically because I think it
justifies your expression of hatred for
those that tiny fraction of people who
are still better off than you.
And also a degree of historical
ignorance that's absolutely staggering
in its magnitude and a complete
indictment of our education system,
which should be indicted in every
possible way.
So now the Marxists might claim to their
benefit,
let's say
with this worldview of class struggle as
being the primary driver of human
history and the well off
socioeconomically because that's pretty
much the only way they defined well off,
which is also something I take great
objection to because there's lots of
hierarchies in the world and there are
many important hierarchies and not all
of them can be reduced to socioeconomic
status by any stretch of the
imagination.
Imagine if you are 80 years old and you
had $20 million,
you know,
you might be perfectly happy to get rid
of all that money if you could be 18
again.
So it's,
and you know,
one of the best predictors of wealth in
North America is actually age because
you know,
young people haven't actually had much
time to make money,
whereas old people have had quite a bit
of time.
But the problem with being old enriches
that you're still old.
And that actually turns out to be quite
as serious problem because no matter how
rich you are,
you eventually die and so the money is
the money has a very delimited if
delimited effect with regards to
addressing the fundamental problems of
the suffering of life and we know
perfectly well from the empirical
perspective that once you have enough
money so that the bill collectors aren't
chasing you around.
Essentially something like the
beginnings of a middle class existence
or maybe the upper end of the working
class than additional money has
absolutely no bearing whatsoever on your
psychological wellbeing and that's
actually an indication of the
limitations of material comfort,
let's say as a medication for the,
for the suffering that's attended on
life.
It's another thing that's very weak
about the Marxists and I think very
interestingly contradictory because
they're very anticapitalist in their
structure,
but they're so damn materialistic that
it's absolutely mind boggling because
the Marxists are actually more convinced
that money is useful than most
capitalists as far as I can tell,
because they believe that that money is
in fact the solution to all life's
problems.
The problem is is that just the right
people don't have the money.
And I think that's a staggeringly naive
perspective because there's many,
there's many problems in life that money
just cannot solve and there's a fair
number of them in that it actually makes
worse.
So anyways,
having said all that,
you could also still make the case.
I used to work for a Socialist Party in
Canada when I was a kid about sixth bout
time,
I was 14 till the time I was about 17
before I figured out what was wrong.
Not so much socialism per se,
but with ideology per se.
And I actually admired the socialist
leaders that I had the fortune to be
introduced to because at that point they
were very much a voice for the working
class.
A lot of union leaders and people like
that,
you know,
they're classic Democratic Socialists on
the Labor end of the distribution.
And it's absolutely necessary for labor
and the working class to have a
political voice,
something the Democrats might keep in
mind.
So when maybe they wouldn't lose their
elections quite so frequently.
I really think it's appalling,
you know,
because it's necessary for the working
class to have a political voice.
So and to have that transformed into
identity politics is a real catastrophe.
Anyways.
I think that the people that I met,
many of them were genuinely concerned
with the problems of the working class
and you know,
more power to them.
And so I think there are people on the
left who,
who genuinely are trying to make a
difference for people who could use a a
fair shot at opportunity in life.
But at the same time I noticed that a
tremendous number of the p of especially
the lower and worker,
a party worker protest or types were
more peevish and resentful than
goodhearted and kind.
And it was about that time that I came
across George Orwell's famous critique
of left wing thinking and in the UK when
in a book called road to Wigan Pier,
where he basically made the claim that
the socialists that he knew,
especially the middle class ones,
didn't give a damn about the poor.
They just hated the rich.
And that's,
I mean,
that is something we're thinking about
for a very long period of time because
hatred actually turns out to be a very
powerful motivation,
you know?
And,
and if you think about the sorts of
things that happened in the Soviet Union
and all these places that were supposed
to be worker's Paradise,
this,
if you look at the outcome and you had
to infer whether it was goodness of
heart and kind heartedness and care for
the working man that produced the
genocides or outright bitter,
resentful,
resentment and hatred,
it's a lot easier to draw a causal path
from the negative emotion to the
outcome.
Then from the positive kind hearted
benevolence to that,
you just don't get gulags out of
benevolence.
That's just not how it works.
So I think the bloody historical
evidence is clear.
Um,
although I have read the most
convoluted,
pathological,
pathetic,
twisted rationalizations of what
happens,
stay installing this Russia that you
could possibly manufacturer,
it's as if an a stack of corpses that
would reach halfway to the moon isn't
enough evidence for the pathology of a
certain form of belief.
So some people can't be convinced by
anyone's death,
but their own,
I suppose so.
So you know,
now I want to talk about postmodernism a
little bit.
Well,
it seems to me that's my Michel Foucault
in the middle and a more reprehensible
individual.
You could hardly ever discover or even
dream up no matter how twisted your
imagination and Fuko and Dara dye would
say.
There's more.
But I would say they're the two
architects of the,
of the,
of the postmodernist movement.
And in brief,
I think what they did was in the late
sixties and early seventies they were
avowed Marxist some way,
lot way after anyone with any shred of
ethical decency had stopped being a
Marxist.
By that time,
even John Paul Sartre had woken up
enough to figure out that the Soviets
hadn't ushered in the Kingdom of Heaven,
know he had evidence stretching back 45
years that he could have attended to if
he would have been willing to open his
eyes,
talk about bad faith,
which was his crutch,
ethical critique,
essentially.
It's something quite staggering.
The postmodernists knew that they were
pretty much done with regards to pushing
their classic Marxism by the late
sixties and early seventies because the
evidence that Stellan us Russia not only
stalinists certainly lennon was no,
no saint by any stretch of the
imagination that the killing certainly
got underway while he was still alive
and and continued after Stellan was dead
as well.
Although perhaps with not the same
degree of brutality and efficiency.
And then there is of course Maoist China
where the estimates,
you know,
nobody knows how many people died under
Mao,
but the estimates are run as high as 100
million people,
which actually turns out to be quite a
few people in the fact that we can't
keep count accurately,
you know,
without an error margin of something in
the tens of millions just tells you
exactly how horrible the situation was.
They transformed the Marxist dialogue
of,
of rich versus poor into oh pressed
versus oppressor and Fuko in particular
who never fit in anywhere and who was an
outcast in many ways an a bitter one in
as suicidal one his entire life did
everything he possibly could with is
staggering Iq to figure out every
treacherous way possible to undermine
the structure that wouldn't accept him
in all his peculiarity.
And it's no wonder because there'd be no
way of making a structure that could
possibly function if it was composed of
people who were as peculiar,
bitter and resentful as Michel Fuko.
So you couldn't imagine this functioning
society that would be composed of
individuals with his particular makeup.
In any case,
he did put his brain to work trying to
figure out a way how to resurrect
Marxism under a new guys,
let's say,
and B,
how to justify the fact that it wasn't
his problem,
that he was an outsider.
It was actually everyone else's problem
and he did a pretty damn good job of
that and laid the groundwork for this.
For the,
what would you call it,
the rise of the marginalized against the
center and Darin is thinking is very
much the same.
You know dare.
Even though Fuco and Derrida hated each
other and and regarded each other as
intellectual charlatans,
which was about the only thing either of
them was ever really correct about,
so
Dara Dad was also an in some ways is
even more treacherous thinker because he
makes the claim in some sense that I
think a political system has a center
around which the majority congregate.
Let's say it's,
it's,
it's quite similar to two ficos analysis
and that there are,
there are people who are outside the
category system and then,
which is obviously true because no
matter how you categorize people,
there are certain people inside the
category in certain people outside.
That's actually why you categorize
things,
right?
Because of every category holds every
entity.
Then every,
every cognitive operation is infinitely
complex.
You can't manage that way to categorize.
You have to include and exclude.
It's in the very nature of
categorization and you can't just scrap
categorization because without
simplification and categorization,
you actually can't function in the
world.
You just die,
right?
You die of excess stress.
It's something like something like that
happens to schizophrenia people because
their category systems breakdown,
they're completely incapable of
functioning in the world as a
consequence of that anyways.
Um,
then you know,
uh,
Derrida went and Fuko as well went a
step farther and this is one of the
incredibly crooked elements of their
thinking.
I think another slight of hand,
which was well category systems,
exclude political systems,
exclude economic systems,
exclude any hierarchy of value excludes
obviously because if there was a
hierarchy of value,
some things are more valuable than
others and the less valuable things are
excluded because otherwise it wouldn't
be a hierarchy of value.
But the,
the next claim they essentially make is
that the reason that those hierarchies
of value are constructed isn't to
produce whatever it is that's a value,
but to exclude and to maintain the
structure of power that's intrinsic to
the hierarchy of value.
And that's a,
that's an unbelievably crooked claim
because there are multiple reasons why a
hierarchy of value might be put into
place there.
Hierarchies of beauty and there's
hierarchies of competence,
hierarchies of intelligence and,
and attractiveness and,
and athletic ability and musical talent.
There's multiple hierarchies.
And in order for those things to exist
at a high order,
in order for us to,
to,
to laud,
uh,
what would you say?
Musical genius,
we have to excuse all the people.
We have to exclude all the people who
can only squawk their clarinet from the
hierarchy because otherwise you don't
have any music and there's no option,
there's no direction.
And so to claim that the purpose of the
hierarchy is to exclude,
it's unbelievably crooked and it's,
it's central claim for both,
for both [inaudible] and Darin.
It's one of those slights of hands that
people don't quite notice,
but that have absolutely catastrophic
effects.
Now for foucault and Derrida,
they,
you could,
here's how you could imagine their world
essentially.
Um,
you know,
for the,
for the philosopher Hobbes,
um,
life was nasty,
brutish and short,
and people were at each other's throats
in the state of nature,
right?
But hubs really thought about that as a,
as a,
as the chaos of individuals.
And he believed that a central authority
had to exert force in order to organize
that intrinsic chaos so that some degree
of peace could rate.
It's kind of the opposite of John Shock
Russo's theory,
which was that human beings were
intrinsically good and,
and the state,
the government was intrinsically bad and
that all of what made people evil derive
from the state.
Um,
I would say if you put hobbes and
Rousseau together,
you actually get the truth,
even though they do seem to be coming at
it from opposite perspectives because
people are actually good and evil.
And so social structures are also good
and evil.
And you know,
it's paradoxical and we don't like
paradoxical categories,
but that's still how it is.
What,
what foucault and Derrida and the
postmodernists did was that they kind of
added the collective element to that.
So they're hobbsy and world isn't a
world of individuals struggling against
one another in the initial state of
warlike nature.
It's,
it's groups of individuals bound by
whatever their identity happens to be
struggling against each,
each other for power.
Because in the postmodern,
neo Marxist universe,
there's nothing but power.
And there's a variety of reasons for
that.
Partly it's because the postmodernists
don't admit that there are any standards
outside of arbitrary opinion.
Essentially.
They don't really believe in the real
world,
which is why they can generate critiques
of science,
for example,
which is increasingly characterized is
nothing but part of the euro centric
patriarchies um,
what would you call desire to impose
their power structure on the rest of the
world despite the fact that it also
makes planes fly in computers operate
and,
and well,
you know,
yeah,
exactly.
So,
and it's a rare bloody,
um,
social justice warrior that doesn't have
an iphone or a android that wouldn't
work if quantum mechanics wasn't
actually correct.
Because the fact that quantum matt
mechanics is correct is one of the
reasons why these unbelievably,
highly developed pieces of technology
actually function.
So they bitch and whine about the
patriarchal,
patriarchal underpinnings of Eurocentric
Science and use the gadgets all the time
to aggregate,
to complain about it.
So it's really pretty appalling.
So anyways,
anyways,
the worldview of the,
of the postmodern neo marxists is that
everybody is basically not an
individual.
Um,
cause that's really a fiction and a
eurocentric patriarchal fiction at that,
but a member of whatever their identity
group happens to be.
And there's no real possibility of
communication between identity groups,
hence phenomena like cultural
appropriation.
Um,
and so it's a war of all groups against
all groups and it's all,
it's nothing but a struggle for power
and there's no higher order ethic to be
referred to because for the
postmodernists,
um,
there is no such thing as a higher order
ethic.
There is no such thing as a uniting
narrative.
That's,
that's a hallmark of their thinking.
Now of course,
that doesn't work out in practice
because without an ethic or a higher
order value,
there isn't anything you can do with
your life because you keep undermining
yourself.
If everything's just a women subjective,
there's and there's no hierarchy of
values than what the hell do you do when
you get up in the morning.
If one thing isn't better than the
other,
you might as well just lay there and
smother yourself with a pillow would be
a lot easier than opening your eyes and
struggling in the world so so it's
completely,
it's a self defeating philosophy and I
think that's part of the reason why it's
more or less self evident that it's a
mask for the continuation of Marxism
because at least Marxism has as one of
its advantages at direction.
It's an ethic,
right?
You have something to struggle against
even though what you're struggling
against is certainly one of the things
that you actually rely on and second,
something that you have to oversimplify
in a very ungrateful and resentful way
to justify fighting against it to begin
with.
And that's especially true in western
cultures because as pathological as they
certainly are,
which is approximately as pathological
as all of you are,
there are a lot less pathological than
almost everything that's ever happened
and pretty much everything that's
currently happening elsewhere in the
world.
And you can kind of tell that by the
fact that people tend to come to
immigrate to the West rather than the
reverse.
Now,
you know,
the postmodern neo Marxists would have
an answer to that,
which would be the only reason the west
functions is cause it's raped the rest
of the,
of humanity and the planet.
But you know,
the less said about that,
the better.
And Marx was wrong about this too.
The proletarians have nothing to lose,
but our chains,
that actually wasn't true.
They lost their food.
Yeah.
You might see that happening again in
Venezuela where they,
where they're having a hard time in the
middle class are having a hard time
getting toilet paper,
which has a lot less funny than it
sounds.
They lost their families.
That's good.
They lost their land.
They lost their freedom.
They lost.
They lost their right to exist without
pain.
They lost the right to honestly suffer
and talk about it,
which is a terrible thing to lose,
lose.
And then they lost their lives.
So that was wrong.
And he can smile all you want about it.
But it wasn't very cute.
This is nice.
I saw this on twitter today.
When Karl Marx died in 1883 the average
Englishman was three times richer than
he was when weren't.
Mark's was born in 1818 that's world GDP
per person in 19 1990 international
dollars.
And you'll see that there's an
unbelievable spike.
And it happened at about 1895 was,
let's,
let's put it this way.
It was precisely and exactly the
opposite of what the Marxists predicted.
But you know,
when your predictions fail and you're an
idiot log,
you just gerrymander the axioms of your
theory because otherwise you'd have to
drop the damn thing.
And then you're plunged into a state of
existential chaos,
which is no joke.
And you have to reformulate yourself.
So you know,
you,
you don't want to underestimate the
difficulty of doing that.
But,
but it's still relatively amusing,
especially when you consider that that
unbelievable increase in gross domestic
product per person actually happened
despite the best efforts of the Marxists
to prevent it from happening.
And so God only knows we were,
we would be if 120 million people
weren't sacrificed painfully and
pointlessly in the 20th century to this
idiot God of socialist utopia.
It was turned out to be murderous beyond
comprehension,
postmodernism and attitude of
skepticism,
irony toward a skepticism towards
everything.
But postmodernism,
I might add irony toward rejection of
grand narratives.
That's a lot bigger a problem than you
think because actually the things that
unite people are grand narratives.
You know,
a narrative is a,
as a cognitive structure that orients
you towards an ideal.
That's what a narrative is.
You know,
if you go see a movie,
which is a narrative,
the hero is up to something.
First of all,
there is a hero because why the hell go
to the movie?
Otherwise you don't want to watch a
bunch of people bumble around randomly.
There's no,
you're not interested in that at all.
You want to see someone who has a
problem to solve and who at,
who's applying an ethic to the solution
of that problem.
It can be a bad ethnic.
That would be an Antihero,
right?
Could be a pathological ethic.
That's a good object lesson anyways,
but it's certainly an ethic.
And so it's grand narratives that unite
people and when the postmodernist become
skeptical about the grand narrative is
what that essentially means is that
they're demolishing the,
the hyper truths.
I would say the fictions,
the,
the true fictions that unite us as
people and stop us from being at each
other's throats,
enable us to compete and to cooperate in
a peaceful and productive manner,
at least some of the time,
which is a miracle in and of itself and
should be regarded as such.
Right?
I mean,
we're so blind in the west to the
miraculous nature of our culture that
it's,
well,
it's a consequence of being privileged,
let's say.
Although I hate that word,
we could call it fortunate.
You know,
when I am in Herzliya leak came to
Holland,
one of the things that's really struck
me when I read her book infidel,
um,
she was very taken aback by the fact
that you could stop by a bus,
a bus stop,
and there'd be a little digital display
there that said when the bus was coming
and when the digital display said the
bus was coming,
then the bus would show up and she just
couldn't accustom yourself to that.
It was like an existential produced
existential terror.
And it's no wonder because you just
think about how bloody impossible that
is.
That's impossible.
I mean the Dutch could manage it because
they manage,
you know,
a dozen impossible things before
breakfast.
They live under water for God's sake.
So,
but you know,
she was also absolutely amazed that you
could go ask policemen for help and they
wouldn't just hurt you and take all your
money.
And that is also another form of
miracle.
The kind of thing that we just take for
granted,
skepticism towards ideologies and
universalism.
Well,
we can scrap the ideology part,
including objective notions of reason,
human nature,
social progress,
absolute truth,
and objective reality.
And it's an unbelievably corrosive,
it's an unbelievably corrosive system of
thought because first of all,
it defines hierarchy as power.
And that's actually technically wrong.
Even friends to wall who's been studying
chimpanzee hierarchies has established
quite clearly that the most brutal and
powerful Elfa chimp is not the one who
establishes the most stable dominance
hierarchies,
or let's call them social hierarchies
because the brutal tyrant chimp gets
torn apart by two subordinate chimps,
three quarters as strong as him.
As soon as he turns a blind eye,
the more stable hierarchies even among
chimps,
are ones that are,
that are governed by someone.
You know,
when a chimp that's got some physical
power in some capacity for intimidation,
but who's perfectly capable of
establishing reciprocal relationships
with other male and female chimps so
that he's got friends and allies around
them,
it stabilizes it's rules,
so to speak.
So the idea that hierarchies in,
in functioning societies are primarily a
consequence of power,
is cynical beyond belief,
apart from being wrong.
So,
and it also destroys the idea of a
hierarchy of competence,
which I really think is one of the
reasons for the theory to begin with
because we know even from the empirical
data that in Western societies,
the best two predictors of longterm life
success,
our intelligence and conscientiousness,
and they do a pretty good job of
predicting longterm life success
accounting for about 25 to 30% of the
variance,
which is a lot by social science
standards and it's kind of a testament
to the integrity of our societies that
complex jobs tend to be filled by
intelligent,
hardworking people and thank God for
that because who the hell do you want
running them?
You don't want to be doing that
randomly.
Most of those things are incredibly
complex and difficult and so you better
have disciplined people who were willing
to work 60 hours a week and who are
super smart governing those things are,
or the lights go off and they should be
off right now because it's impossible to
keep a power grid functioning.
It's not like it.
It's not like entropy isn't trying to
tear it to bits at every second,
right?
There are thousands of people out there
working madly to stop this thing from
doing what it should be doing,
which is to fail.
And so competence is everywhere and it's
abs.
I mean you think about how many
competent people have to be working
behind the scenes so that you can all
come here,
you know,
in your leisure fundamentally and sit
for two hours peacefully in a lecture.
It's absolutely beyond belief.
So I think that they were after the
destruction of the idea of competence
itself and we're getting,
we're walking down that road very,
very rapidly as well as trying to
destroy the idea of the world.
And that's part of the,
what would you call it,
the attempt to,
to insist that there's no such thing
outside the text,
which was one of Derrida's great
statements.
There's no such thing outside the text.
And what he meant by that in some sense
was everything is interpretation and
there is a manner in which that's true,
but it's not the kind of final truth
that the postmodernists likes.
Like to think it is,
there are a little too tangled up in
language.
So,
and that's not a good thing.
So here's where we're at with regards to
the um,
to the spread of postmodern neo Marxist
ideas.
And these are,
see,
I've been trying,
you know how you can identify the right
wingers you don't want to hang around
with because they talk about white
supremacy and maybe they have a
swastika.
It's like that's a little sign saying if
you're a conservative,
move away from those people.
And most conservatives do that in the
aftermath of Charlottesville.
For example,
Shapiro immediately distanced himself
from the radical right.
And William Buckley did the same thing
in the 1960 [inaudible] 1970s when he
divorced himself from the John Birch
society.
Conservatives are pretty good at putting
borders around things.
In fact,
that's a good definition of a
conservative.
I'm serious.
Like conservatives like to have borders
around things,
whereas liberals think,
well if you have too many borders,
information can't flow.
And that's true.
And the Conservatives say no borders
chaos and the chaos and the liberals say
too many borders,
stagnation.
And those are both right,
so you have to argue about how thick the
borders should be.
But anyways,
liberals have a hell of a time drawing
borders and that means they can't
separate themselves from the radical
leftists who have absolutely no interest
whatsoever in sustaining the genuine
liberals.
They just use them as useful idiots to
take a phrase from the Soviet Union.
And here are the hallmarks,
I think,
of the pathological left.
I think that if someone is pushing this
quaternary on you,
then you should,
you should be very suspicious of them in
every possible way and you should resist
it as much as you possibly can.
Diversity,
inclusivity,
well,
you know,
those are,
those are the minor demons of the
radical left.
Let's say equity.
It's like,
no,
we're not going there.
That's equality of outcome,
not equality of opportunity and equality
of outcome.
I'll tell you why in a bit is an
absolutely pathological idea.
There's nothing about it that's good.
It's impossible to implement.
It's fundamentally motivated by
resentment and it's a lie.
So I liked fact that those three make
the acronym die though because that
seems to be approximately appropriate.
So,
and then the worst of the bunch is white
privilege because as far as I'm
concerned,
there's absolutely no difference between
that statement and an outright racist
slur.
They're the same thing.
So,
and it's quite straight forward.
Why it's not,
it doesn't take a bloody genius to
figure this out.
I mean what constitutes racism?
It's the description of the hypothetical
qualities of group to all the
individuals who compose that group.
So white privileged.
It's like even the people who are
interested in intersectionality you'd
think would have some problem with that.
It's like what about all the poor white
people while they're more privileged
than the poor people who aren't white I
suppose.
But,
but you know,
that's a pretty bloody week argument in
my estimation.
And to call it privilege is also
something.
And to associate it with race per se is
also something extraordinarily
interesting.
And we'll get into that a little bit.
So let's talk about diversity.
Okay,
well first of all,
we have to define it.
You know,
and Jonathan Hyde has been trying to
define it as diversity of opinion.
I think it might be useful to define it
as diversity of personality because
there's actually more variability in
personality within groups of people
regardless of the groups than there is
between groups of people.
So that should be said.
Again,
there's more variability within groups
of people then between groups of people
and to state otherwise is to state
something that is in fact categorically
racist.
Because if I said,
well,
there's more difference between groups
of people than within groups,
then I'm saying that each racial group
is an entity unto itself,
which could be true but happens to
actually not be.
So the diversity definition is really
quite interesting in right now that's
being defined by race,
sex,
or gender,
sexual orientation and disability.
Although there's a very large number of
other potential dimensions of,
of difference that could be included in
the list of oppressed versus oppressor.
That's actually why intersectionality
has emerged,
you know,
because people figured out,
well,
you know,
you're having a harder time if you're
black,
let's say,
and you're having a harder time if
you're a woman,
depending on how you define harder time,
um,
but you're even having a harder time.
If you're a black woman,
there's an intersection there.
It's like,
okay,
fine.
Well where are we going to stop with the
intersections?
I figured out the other day,
if you,
if each of those categories could be
differentiated into a hundred sub units,
you know,
who knows how many there are with
gender,
sex,
there's an infinite number of them
apparently.
Um,
then you need six dimensions before
you're down to one in a billion.
So six dimensions of intersectionality
brings you down to the level of the
individual,
which is the flaw in,
what would you call it?
Uh,
uh,
identity politics theory manifesting
itself as an internal contradiction.
So I think that's very funny.
If you push,
if you push intersectionality to its
final frontier,
you break down every one to the level of
the individual,
which is actually what I think western
culture figured out about 4,000 years
ago is that the ultimate minority is the
individual and the only,
and the fairest society is one where
individuals are allowed to rise to the
level of their ability.
Because how,
what are you going to do?
You're going to co-vary out all their
differences.
It's impossible.
It's technically impossible.
There's given postmodern logic itself.
There's an infinite number of ways to
categorize a finite number of facts.
So how are you going to determine which
dimensions of difference are the ones
that should be adjusted for the
individual?
Since there's an unlimited number of
dimensions of variability,
intelligence,
height,
attractiveness,
age,
personality,
there's five dimensions of personality,
socioeconomic class,
right?
Degree of historical oppression.
You know,
I that can be seriously multiplied
endlessly.
So what are you going to do control for
all those?
It's like,
good luck.
That's never going to happen.
And then diversity in the service of
what exactly?
You know,
the idea that a group of people that's
racially diverse is better at problem
solving.
Then a group of people who isn't there
isn't a shred of evidence to support
that idea.
It's a presupposition,
a supposition,
and it also brings you back to something
like racial essential.
Is it right?
I mean so,
so in every possible way logically and
practically,
it's a nonstarter and I think the
diversity issue is irrelevant anyways
because I think the fundamental reason
that the postmodern neil marks has
pushed diversity is because it's another
way that they can attack the power
structure that they regard as
patriarchal and oppressive say,
well,
it's in the service of the working class
and the oppressed.
It's like we already covered that a
little bit with regards to the Marxists
claims to be working on the side of the
working class when in fact what really
happened was that many of them,
perhaps most were killed and the ones
that weren't killed were certainly at
least made extraordinarily miserable,
which may be is even better than killing
them.
If you're particularly malevolent
today and see one of the things that's
happening that's quite pathological is
and very interesting is that the
postmodernists,
and this is I think a direct consequence
of training of activists in universities
and the universities have more to be
ashamed of,
then you could list in a two hour
lecture.
I think someone estimated today that
about 4,000 colleges and universities
will go bankrupt in the u s and the next
10 years.
And as far as I'm concerned,
the faster the better.
So,
so the Toronto District School Board
announced recently that it will now give
priority to the hiring of diverse staff,
especially in racialized backgrounds.
Why in,
I don't know.
I suspect it's because of the pope.
People who wrote the damn policy are
functionally illiterate,
but you'd certainly think that if you
looked at the intelligence of their
policies and so what's that priority to
the hiring of diverse staff,
especially in racialized backgrounds.
What the hell did that mean?
I tweeted that if you weren't going to
hire straight white CIS is,
it's,
I guess this gendered is the same thing,
but we use it just because it's such a
hateful phrase.
If you're not going to hire a straight
CIS gendered men as teachers,
why the hell do you let them into the
faculties of education to begin with?
The amount as well,
just exclude them before they waste four
years on your,
what would you call them?
Ideologically rigid pseudo educational
nonsense,
equity.
This is something I really like.
There's the little happy thing,
equality of opportunity on the left
versus equity on the right.
You see the little kid gets to lift up
and eat the apple.
Isn't that lovely?
But what happens really inequity is that
everyone gets to have exactly the same
depth of grave and they're perfectly
equal when they're six feet under.
And if you not,
if you don't believe that,
then you can look at what happened in
the Ukraine in the 1930s during the hall
on the door when the Russians decided
that with the Soviets decided that it
was perfectly reasonable to ascribe
class guilt to the successful farmers
and wipe them out and then starve 6
million Ukrainians to death,
thus establishing a certain equality.
This woman,
she's,
I remind this is the shakespeare quote
one,
I think it's from Richard the third,
but I'm not exactly sure one can smile
and smile and smile and still be a
villain.
And you know,
she's a lovely looking old grandmotherly
type of creature.
But that doesn't mean that everything
that she did wasn't pathological beyond
belief and it was her,
her,
what would you call them?
Uh,
a second rate,
pseudo intellectual,
uh,
opinionated meanderings that produced
the,
the concept of white privilege.
And what she did was make a list of all
the ways that she felt that she was
particularly privileged in society.
That was her bloody methodology.
And that's the sort of methodology that
these pseudo disciplines that have
invaded the universities get away with
because the rest of the faculty are too
damn timid to stand up and say the
emperor has no clothes.
Better stand up and say something about
it pretty soon because you can bloody
well be sure that they're coming for the
physicians and the evolutionaries
biologists and psychologists next.
And they're not weak and they're well
organized.
And so it's a very terrible thing.
So anyways,
the papers rely on personal examples
because we know how it methodologically
rigorous that is of unearned advantage
as Mac.
But that whole methodology thing,
that rigorous methodology,
that's just another manifestation of the
euro centric patriarchy.
So you don't have to be concerned about
your damn methodology when you have your
personal experience to rely on.
And so here's the privileges.
I can't.
If I wished to arrange,
arrange to be in the company of people
of my race,
most of the time,
if I should need to move,
I can be pretty sure of renting or
purchasing housing in an area which I
can afford in which I would want to
live.
I can be pretty sure that my neighbors
in such a location will be neutral or
pleasant to me unless they know that I'm
the author of the fundamental paper on
white privilege.
I can go shopping alone most of the
time,
pretty well assured that I will not be
followed or harassed.
It's like,
well,
the first thing is,
is lot of those so called privileges are
just the consequence of living in a
reasonably civilized society and apply
to pretty much everyone.
And the second thing is is that there's
no reason to associate this with race.
That's another one of these absolutely
pathological sleights of hand.
How about we call it majority privilege.
You think that's not the case for the
majority members of every society that's
ever function that's actually been
functional?
Obviously there's a majority advantage.
If there wasn't a bloody majority
advantage,
people wouldn't make societies the whole
point of making a society so that the
people within the society have the
advantages.
So now you might say,
well,
when people are being integrated into
this society,
they should be given.
Those advantages are provided with those
advantages when they join the club,
so to speak,
as rapidly as possible.
And obviously that's the case.
But to attribute this level of civility
and safety to some hypothetical
construct like white privileges,
well it's exactly what you'd expect from
people who,
who,
whose response to the idea of
methodology is,
but that's just a social construct like
everything else is,
there's the class enemies from the
Ukraine,
the Kulaks,
right.
They were the farmers who were
productive in the 1920s and before had
mirror recently emerged from the peasant
class.
They were all rounded up and shot and
raped and robbed and then sent to
Siberia to freeze to death or to die of
some infectious disease because to them,
guilt was attributed as a consequence of
their membership of a class.
And I can tell you if there are people
around you that are attributing guilt to
you because of your membership in a
class,
they are not your friends.
In fact,
they're the friends of no one and
they're contributing to this intense
state of political polarization and
racial disharmony.
That seems to be me to be expanding at
an exponential rate.
It's not good.
I really liked this juxtaposition of
pictures.
So when the Soviets collectivize the
farms in the Ukraine,
they take,
took all the grain that the Ukrainians
had had had produced,
which wasn't very much because they'd
collectivize the farms and they shipped
it all to the cities.
And then the rule was that if you are a
starving Ukrainian woman who had
children and you went out in the field
and you picked up individual half rotten
bits of grain to feed your kids,
that that was,
that was a,
no offense punishable by death.
You were supposed to turn that in to the
local authority so they could ship that
to the city too.
So on the one hand you have nice picture
here of the bags of grain that we're
heroically going into the cities and in
the other hand you have a picture of the
bodies that were the cost of doing
precisely that.
So let's look at the failures of this
system.
Well you,
you could list them forever.
The death of the cool acts that was
right off the bat,
which is why I use it.
It was very,
very early in the,
in the collectivization process.
Then the Ukrainian famine,
which I mean,
I don't know how often that's taught in
high schools in the United States and
Canada,
but I would suspect never is the answer
to that,
the rise of the Gulag state because it
turned out that the bloody Soviet Union
couldn't function unless they enslaved
everybody and made them work the death
of tens of millions.
It's uncountable.
The 56 crackdown on Hungary,
the 68 invasion of Czechoslovakia,
not dimension,
the whole Cold War that put the whole
goddamn world at risk from 1962 to 1989
and that still rear is rearing its ugly
head with our current dispute with North
Korea,
which is the last remaining,
let's call it ghoulag like Soviet state,
so there's the death counts.
Perhaps that's a relatively conservative
estimate,
eight to 61 million in the Soviet Union.
It was quite a margin of error,
wouldn't you say?
That's the red terror,
the great purge,
the national operations of the end kvd
later the KGB,
the great purge in Mongolia,
Soviet killings during World War II,
the People's Republic of China,
land reform,
land reform.
That's how,
that's how you,
that's what you call it.
When you take land that grows food and
turn it into land that's just full of
corpses.
That's land reform and the suppression
of counter-revolutionaries the great
leap forward.
That was a good one.
The great proletarian cultural
revolution,
Cambodian,
the killing fields and then a list of
other countries.
Every single place where these
pathological ideas were put into
practice became what you might describe
as the literal equivalent of hell on
earth so rapidly that it was a kind of
miracle in and of itself.
And yet we still,
you know,
what is it,
one out of five social scientists in
American universities regard themselves
as Marxists.
It's like,
what the hell?
Really,
really?
What is going on with that?
I don't understand that in the least.
You know,
I don't understand why that pathological
ideology that's so murderous,
so intensely murderers and so closely
tied to the genocides from a causal
perspective can,
cannot have accreted to at the same,
what would you call an honorable,
uhh,
honorable state that Nazi-ism has
accrued to itself.
What's going on?
Why?
Why don't we see it that way?
I don't understand that.
I mean,
maybe it's because of the hypothetical
universal utopia that the damn Soviets
were aiming at.
Maybe you could get away with that in
1895 you know,
or maybe after world war one when things
were brutal and the monarchies of Europe
were collapsing and everything was
chaotic,
you didn't know that your Utopian ideas,
we're going to result in an absolute
catastrophe,
but it's a hundred years after that now
almost to the day and when the evidence
is clearly in I'm a Marxist,
it's no,
you're just jealous because you don't
make as much as a bloody investment
banker.
So that's why you're a bloody
Marxist.
Fewer paid four times as much.
You'd be a capitalist so fast it would
make your head spin.
I'm going to talk for 15 more minutes
because we started a little late and I
do want to get through this.
So what's the problem?
Well,
we already discussed it and I want to
show you a different way of
conceptualizing it.
This is based on some of the work that
I've done on archetypes and I think of,
I think of archetypes,
has images,
stick representations of the axioms of
thought.
That's a reasonable way of,
or maybe of the axioms of being itself.
There are categories of being pain is a
category of being,
for example,
a suffering limitation.
Finitude.
Those are all categories of being and
they're very realistic.
They're the fundamental elements of
existence.
Essentially.
It's a different different in some sense
than a materialist view point,
you know,
because the materialists make the claim
and perfectly reasonable in some sense
that the fundamental realities are
material,
but they're only the fundamental
realities in some sense if you define
them that way,
not that that isn't useful and not that
you can't derive objective truth that's
pragmatically useful from that,
but the fundamental realities of life
have a lot more to do with motivation
and emotion,
especially with regards to suffering.
And so that is the unsolved problem of
human existence.
And we talked about the different ways
of conceptualizing that and I want to
walk you quickly through some of my
thinking about the root,
the true roots of of suffering and human
vulnerability.
And I think of this as an antidote to
ideological possession.
I think that this is the fundamental map
of religious belief.
And I'll walk you through it very
quickly.
And that what happens,
what happens in the case of an ideology
is an ideology takes a fragment of a
religious belief system and expands it
up into a totality and has its motive
power because it draws on these
underlying religious slash archetipal
narratives for its power.
So for example,
you know the,
the idea of the future socialist utopia
is very,
very similar to the idea of the Kingdom
of heaven on earth.
It was always,
you know,
that's a cardinal element of,
of,
of the three western major religions.
So here's a way of conceptualizing
existence.
And each of these levels of
conceptualization have their own
symbolic representations.
And you can see these what portrayed
consistently throughout the narratives
that we use to guide our existence.
Even the ones that we don't understand
explicitly,
they come up in,
in,
in movies and in and in books and in
myths and the stories we tell each other
and in our dreams and our imagination
constantly.
So they're really the categories of the
imagination.
And so the first category and the one
that's most difficult to,
I called the dragon
of chaos.
It's sort of the outer most circle.
That's a good illustration of it.
They're the dragon is a very large,
a very common symbol worldwide.
And an anthropologist slash biologist
who I recently read called it a sneak
cat bird,
which I really liked.
Um,
and he thought about it as an amalgam of
the,
of the idea of Predator,
you know,
because our tree dwelling ancestors and
after that we're basically prayed on
burt by birds of prey by predatory cats
and by snakes and so well and God only
knows how much,
how many times fire did the men as well.
So a fire breathing tree,
cat tree,
snake bird is a,
is a very good representation of the
category of everything that's out there
in the unknown that can do you in.
And that become elaborated over the
course of time into the idea of the
dragon that hoards gold or that hoards
virgins for that matter.
The idea being that human beings are
half pray and half Predator.
And so that we have to make a
representation of that which exists
beyond our comprehension that can do
[inaudible].
And so that's the,
the dragon of chaos,
let's say.
But also come to understand that
confronting that voluntarily is the
appropriate way to gather new
information and to survive.
And that's really the fundamental human
story,
fundamental human stories to go boldly
where no one has gone before and what
you encounter are the terrible dragons
that exist beyond your field of
comprehension.
And if you can manage that forthrightly,
then you gathered the kind of
information and riches that enables you
to develop yourself,
character logically,
and to benefit your community.
That's the fundamental story of mankind,
the fundamental positive story.
And that's the underpinning of the hero
mythology.
So,
which is a lovely antidote to
ideological presupposition.
So that's the outer most,
the,
the outer most reality you would say.
That's the unknown unknowns that Donald
Rumsfeld,
uh,
referred to and nested inside that are
the terrible things about life that you
actually encounter,
that you,
they're not the hypothetical things that
might get you there.
The actual things that you encounter
that you don't know.
And some of those are positive and some
of those are negative,
you know,
and,
and that can even flip because sometimes
your life is turned upside down by let's
say by a rejection from someone you love
should be a good example of the terrible
mother that's the great mother on the
outer ring.
Um,
but that can mature you and make you
wake up as well.
And so the,
the encounter with,
with these,
with the things that transcend your,
what would you call it,
your competence or also things that can
make you grow and mature.
So you could think of the great mother
as nature and the great father as
culture and the individual as the person
who is enveloped by culture.
And by nature,
when you move to the fringes of your
culture,
you encounter nature itself.
And that's the case,
let's say geographically,
but it's also the case conceptually,
right?
Because if you're the master
of a field of endeavor,
which is a geographical metaphor,
you move towards the fringes so that you
can stand on the unknown,
encounter something that's new,
transform what's new and inhabitable
territory and extend the dimension of
human capacity.
And so it works on a practical
geographical level of representation,
but also on a,
on a,
on an abstract level.
And so you can also think about it as a
person on an island in an ocean.
That's a good way of thinking about the
human condition.
Except the person has two elements and
the island has two elements.
And so does the ocean and the persons
two elements are classically speaking,
the good and evil that wars in their
heart.
Because it isn't so self evident exactly
where your enemy is.
And it might be the class structure
that's oppressing you,
but it might be the snake in your own
heart.
And it's certainly the case that if you
read people like Viktor Frankl and
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn just to take it
start who were very perspicacious
interpreters of the catastrophes of Nazi
as Admin and and the Soviet Union,
both of their conclusions was.
The fundamental problem with both both
of those systems is that the individuals
within the systems allowed themselves to
be corrupted by what was in their own
hearts.
And so one of the things that's
absolutely horrible,
I think about the Marxist and
postmodernist viewpoint is that it
doesn't attribute any of the pathology
that's all all projected onto the social
world to the individual,
him or herself.
And you might say,
well that's where the fundamental battle
takes place.
And I would also say that the idea that
existence is a battle between good and
evil and it's the battle of the soul is
a consequence of the symbolic
realization of Western civilization.
That the evil that has to be confronted
most forthrightly as actually the
individual that obtains that evil that
obtains to the individual.
And that it's primarily an ethical issue
at the individual level.
And that's what you take responsibility
for.
It.
If you forget that you projected on to
other people,
you take no responsibility for it and
you end up thinking that you're the good
guy.
And you probably shouldn't think that
because if you thought for about 15
minutes about all the stupid things that
you've done in your life,
you could add malevolent things as well.
You could figure out for yourself quite
quickly that the probability that you're
the saint and that everyone else is the
villain is,
is,
is only an indication of precisely how
villainous you are.
So,
and then with regards to the social
structure,
well obviously it's pathological and
tyrannical and corrupted,
deceitful,
you know,
it's,
it's partly a structure of the dad and
people are corrupt to some degree and
willfully blind.
And so that's an archetypal truth.
That's part of the throne.
This,
that we discussed earlier,
you have this infrastructure that
surrounds you both physical and
conceptual and you're,
it's beneficiary and its victim.
It's partly pathological and corrupt.
It's always been that way.
And you're damn lucky that it isn't just
purely corrupt because that's frequently
the case.
And so what your job is not to whine
about the fact that it's corrupt,
that's self evident.
You're job is to straighten yourself up
enough so that you can straighten up the
culture.
And that's the old motif of rescuing
your father from the belly of the whale,
let's say,
which is part of the necessary process
by which people become fully developed
individuals.
What you're supposed to be doing in
university,
in the humanities.
You don't just study the great ideas of
Western culture [inaudible] you just,
you,
you study the pathology of history and
know that it's about you.
And then maybe you try to culture
yourself and discipline yourself to the
point where you have enough of an
internal ethic so that when you take
your place in the patriarchy,
for lack of a better word,
you're going to be a force for good
rather than a force for evil.
And then maybe the damn thing tilts a
bit towards the good instead of the
catastrophe.
And then maybe you've done something
that's worthwhile and then nature.
Well,
you know,
if you,
it's very easy to romanticize nature,
especially if you're a city dweller
who's never had to,
you know,
wander out in the northern woods in the
middle of the summer and get eaten by
black flies and mosquitoes starving to
death while trying to track down an
animal.
It's very easy to romanticize nature.
Of course,
cancer and other diseases tend to
disabuse you of the pure beauty of
nature.
And nature is a very,
very destructive force.
It's,
it's against us all the time as well as
for us.
And another thing that's really not well
balanced in our society is the anti
humanism that's become part and parcel
of radical discussions everywhere.
Human beings are regarded as a cancer on
the planet.
To quote the,
what was that?
The club of Rome,
um,
worrying about the population explosion
and we're all guilty because we're
destroying things as fast as we can
possibly manage.
It's like Jesus,
everything around us is always trying to
kill us.
Most of the time we're just trying to
stay alive.
I mean,
we're not perfect.
We're corrupt and sora social structures
and people get greedy and careless.
But it's not like nature's all shining a
wonderful young lady waiting in the
wilderness to embrace us positively.
It's the old hag that's going to kill
you every possible way and you need to
defend yourself against that.
And you know,
human beings have only been in a
position since 1960 since we ever had
any conceptualization of our potential
to change the planet on a planetary
scale.
It's been like four generations.
You know,
back in the 1890s Thomas Huxley was
commissioned by the English parliament
to,
to investigate the carrying capacity of
the oceans and his,
he was a great biologist.
His report was that there are so damn
many fish in the ocean that every human
being could fish every day for the rest
of his life and catch everything he
possibly could and we wouldn't put a
dent in it.
And that's,
you know,
that's only 120 years ago.
We only woke up to the fact that we
became a planetary force in 1960 it's
like,
what the hell do you expect from people?
You know,
we're trying to get ourselves together
as fast as we can and might be decent of
us to stop with the anti human rhetoric,
which is only going to lead to a bad
end.
You know,
if human beings are nothing but a cancer
on the planet,
then it's the bloody hero who
obliterates them.
Isn't that because it's the hero who
gets rid of cancer?
And when people watch the school
shooters in the mass shooters and they
think,
well,
what is it that motivates people like
that in which they can figure out about
half an hour if they did the proper
reading,
just read what they wrote.
Human beings are a cancer on the planet
being as evil.
Intrinsically,
I'm going to take out everything I can
to show my displeasure with the
structure of reality and then I'm going
to shoot myself just to show you how
little I care.
And if you can't understand that,
then you haven't looked very deeply into
your own heart because there could be a
time in your life.
Believe me,
where something terrible enough happens
to you so that you'll be able to
understand that perfectly.
Here's the Christian representation of
the same thing,
right?
So the great mothers on the outside,
that's nature and then the fathers in
the middle.
And in that representation,
which I really liked,
that's from 13th century,
you see God the father who's a
representation of culture holding the
suffering individual who similar
caneously transcends his suffering.
That's the goal to be the suffering
individual who simultaneously transcends
his suffering.
That's why all those people on the
inside of the open virgin,
which is what that sculpture is called,
our gazing at that image because they're
trying to figure out what the hell it
means.
While people have been gazing at it for
2000 years,
trying to figure out what it means.
And one of the things that you can be
sure of is that that story and what that
image represents is absolutely central
to the integrity of Western
civilization.
Five more minutes.
This is an image of,
of,
I would call it the patriarchy and it's
a lot of lovely image.
It's God the father and he's assimilated
to the sun because well,
because consciousness which is
associated with light is the builder of
culture.
And,
um,
he rules over the walled city.
And so he's the centering idea.
You might say that that unites a
culture.
That's another way of looking at it.
And he's got two hands.
I described them as security and tyranny
altogether order.
And you know,
if you're in a university,
the U of t students complain about this
all the time,
they're 60,000 u of t student,
right?
They feel like numbers,
they feel ignored and no wonder because
their numbers and they are ignored.
It's no wonder they didn't feel that
way.
You know,
and there's huge classes of 1200 people
and they get lost and they think,
God,
that's a pretty evil structure and
uncaring.
It's like,
yeah,
that's exactly right.
But by the same token,
you know,
get to purchase four years of
intellectual freedom and you have all
these people who could at least in
principle,
teach you something and you get an
identity out of the deal.
And if you have half a half a bit of
sense here in the library trying to read
great things and maybe you're not quite
as dopey and useless when you come out
as you were when you went in.
And so it takes with one hand and gives
with the other and you got to understand
that about your position in relationship
to society.
It crushes you in molds you at the same
time,
it limits you and furthers your compute
capability at the same time.
And it's up to you to determine how to
establish a harmonious and productive
relationship with that because that's
one of the fundamental demands of life
that's sort of splits into these two
things.
That's the s the king who devours his
son.
I love that picture and that's,
well that's a society that's become
tyrannical,
right?
I'm the son of the king is the thing
that regenerates the king,
the kings old and he's blind and he's
stupid and he's corrupt and he has a son
and the son is lively and awake and
alert and can see.
And if the father is not pathological,
then he tries to make the sun strong so
that the son can grow up and revitalize
the culture.
And if he's a tyrant,
weld any devours him.
And then he gets old and corrupt and
everything goes to into chaos.
And then there's the benevolent Kane
who's got that properly balanced.
And you see in this picture he's got a
globe but his hand with the cross on top
of it.
And that's means the same thing that
other symbolic image did,
which is that the proper society
supports the suffering individual in his
or her attempts to transcend their
suffering and attain a proper ethical
perspective.
And then the son of the father is the
hero.
That's Hercules'.
I really liked that picture.
So Hercules' goes out into the darkness
and he's got this container and maybe
you can think of that container as a
cultural artifact,
you know,
because the culture protects you from
chaos.
And then the question is,
what are you supposed to do with that
protection?
And the answer is you're supposed to
wear the garb of the lion,
right?
That's the king of the beasts.
So that's supposed to be you and you're
supposed to go out there into the
darkness with your bloody eyes open so
you can discover what's in the darkness
and share with everyone else.
And he's got a club,
they're in his hands and the club was
covered with eyes.
Those are eyes not barbs.
And what that means is that you should
bloody well pay attention and that well
the other element of that it's not
expressed in that image,
is that you should also speak carefully,
pay attention,
and speak carefully,
and then you're the proper son of the
proper farther and you can keep things
functioning and that makes you into
this,
right?
So the city is always threatened,
it's always corrupted,
threatened,
and there's always something outside
that's going to take it down always.
And that's what's represented by the
Dragon.
That little twist and its tail is
something that represents infinity and
the courageous individual goes out of
the damage city to confront the dragon
of chaos and to gain something valuable
as a consequence.
And that's what human are supposed to
do.
That's our destiny.
That's our soul.
That's a better way of thinking about
it.
And some of that terrible dragon is just
the catastrophe and suffering of life
and our continual attempts to transcend
it.
But a tremendous amount of it is also
the malevolence and the evil that exists
in our own hearts and in society.
And perhaps to some degree,
even in the world itself,
you're supposed to wake up and
strengthen yourself and stand up
properly and fortify yourself so that
you're a light that can shine in the
darkness.
And that's something that can withstand
malevolence and tragedy.
And what,
what's your alternative?
You're going to let life crush you and
make you weak and make you resentful and
bitter and then murderous.
You'll take out your rage on everyone
you can and it will only be limited by
your capacity to obtain power.
That's not a good thing.
And so it's this way or it's this way or
a way that leads directly to hell.
And we've certainly seen that plenty of
times in the last hundred years and
you'd think we might have learned our
lesson,
but it takes a lot for people to learn.
And we're in danger of repeating exactly
the same mistakes again.
So,
you know,
it's one thing to complain about the
political polarization and it's another
thing to point fingers out.
The postmodernist send the Neo Marxists,
Steven though they,
they roundly deserve it in my
estimation.
It's another thing to try to figure out
what the proper alternative isn't.
The proper alternative is not,
in my estimation,
to contribute to political polarization.
It's not good.
And it's not that the radical right is
the solution to the radical left.
It's just another catastrophe.
And the only solution that I've been
able to figure out,
and this is as a consequence of much
reading and much thinking,
is that it's up to the individuals in
our society is sort themselves out into
strengthen themselves,
to become wise and alert and to shoulder
the responsibility of being and the
demand,
the ethical demand to pushback
malevolence in their own hearts and in
their society.
And I also believe that,
you know,
it's very difficult for people to
respect themselves because they're weak
and vulnerable and pathetic and
malevolent.
And so it's no,
and they're not what they could be.
And they know it.
And so it's no wonder that people don't
respect themselves and some of that
nature.
And some of that's culture and some of
it's individual weakness.
But one of the things that I've learned,
and it's about the only optimistic
thought I've ever come across,
is that if you have enough courage to
forthrightly,
except the fact that you're vulnerable
and malevolent and you're willing to do
something about it to overcome it,
you can develop enough respect for
yourself so that the terrible weight of
being will not make you mlevel intend
corrupt.
And I don't think that you have anything
better to aim for unless you want blood
in the streets in a pathetic life.
And so you might as well straighten up
and get your act together.
And maybe we've got some chance of
getting through this intermediary period
of chaos that we all face and make
something better out of it instead of
something worse.
So that's what have to say about that.
So thank you.
[inaudible]
I've talked to Peterson has agreed to do
with 30 minutes of question and answers
still.
So,
okay.
So why should just unplug it or shut off
the recording?
Okay.
Oh yes,
yes.
Right.
Sure.
I'll repeat your question.
Okay.
So I heard that you decided not to do
your,
uh,
website thing to analyze the postmodern
his forces and you said that you thought
that it would contribute more and
polarization.
I had lunch with a friend of mine
earlier today who I hadn't seen in 70
years on the radical left and it will
probably be a victim of that kind of
thing if you were to be successful on
that are in many of them,
let's say the shut out of the
university.
Um,
so that seems right to me.
That's a bad way to go.
But what do you think of as the
alternative?
All right.
You've talked to a lot of people who
were sort of in your intellectual orbit
who are kind of fellow travelers.
Do you think the answer is to talk to
people who are further away from you and
have you tried to do that?
I'm sure many,
many people made it would be your life.
Yeah.
You might say that.
Reluctant would be one way of putting
it.
Yeah.
Um,
so the question is,
I had thought about making a website,
well the website was actually made,
cause you know,
if I'm trying to decide whether to do
something,
usually what I do,
because it's really hard to figure out
if you should do something just
hypothetically.
Right.
So one of the ways to figure out if you
should do something is to do it almost
completely and then it's there and then
you're actually thinking about something
real.
And I talked to a bunch of people about
it after it was built and thought that I
wasn't sure it would cause more that
would do more good than harm.
So I put it on hiatus now.
Um,
you know,
one of the unfortunate things that
happened was that the University of
Toronto Faculty Association accused me
of making this website,
you know,
on the basis of things I'd said about
three or four months ago without talking
to me about it.
Because why would they talk to one of
their faculty members being the Faculty
Association.
Um,
and you know,
so I would,
I would,
I,
as I said,
I was wavering back and forth about
whether to not to do this.
And then they came out and attacked me.
And the problem with that is that now if
I say I'm not going to do it,
it looks like they won.
And that's,
and first of all,
I don't see this as a win loss
situation.
I don't like it to be construed that
way.
But the truth of the matter is,
is that when the faculty association
came out and said that,
you know,
it would be wrong for me to do it,
my first response was,
well,
you bastards all be doing it.
Now you can be sure of that.
But that's not a good,
that's not how to think,
right?
That's how to react.
And so you don't do that.
You have your little emotional meltdown
and then you,
you think for like a month and you get
people to talk to and you try to come at
it from a level headed perspective.
So,
uh,
I don't know.
I probably have most luck with youtube
videos and I have a book coming out.
Uh,
I'm supposed to bring a flyer for all of
you,
but you know,
I forgot.
So,
um,
like I always do.
So,
um,
and hopefully that'll be helpful because
it's about individual responsibility
fundamentally.
And,
and truth in particular,
which I think is,
what would you say?
Well,
if you want to adapt to reality,
which is kind of what you have to do
then falsifying it is probably not the
most effective strategy as far as I can
tell.
And it's certainly the case that if you
allow yourself to speak bent words that
you'll end up with a bent character and
then God help you.
So,
you know,
I talked tonight about what I think are
the words that are most dangerous,
diversity,
equity,
inclusivity,
white privilege.
So maybe you know,
the people who are watching the videos
can think about how they might want to
orient themselves in relationship to the
mid level bureaucrats in particular who
are pushing this sort of thing forward
with as much force as they can possibly
manage.
So we'll see.
That's that's the plan at the moment.
Yep.
You never know.
Hello,
any of the lecture
or at least the ones who,
I was wondering if you could talk about
this.
Ideas that are not the cookie cutter one
left and the leftist students like I
have today.
I'm talking about people like me,
they board though they are some,
some of them steeped in Marxism.
The do have validity in the sense that
though we have this thrown this from
heidegger,
there are power hierarchies and
structures.
Though admittedly not all powerful that
do define human interactions that do
dominate people and that do in a sense
or at least in their words,
alienate people from themselves.
Probably the most prominent papers and
the medium is message,
which is what I'm talking about,
which is the production of new
technologies,
the technology itself and the content
producers.
We can think of newspaper articles in
the newspaper,
the distribution of newspapers.
Is it self content as well and how that
defines power structures within people?
Well,
the first thing is is that it's not
particularly useful necessarily to
conceptualize them as power structures
because there are structures with
multiple purposes and there are multiple
structures and so collapsing it to
powers of very bad idea.
The second is that we're in a human
beings are in a constant state of
alienation from the world and from what
they produce.
It's,
that's what human,
if you had to define human beings,
that would be the definition.
Those creatures that are in a constant
state of alienation from themselves,
culture and the world.
Now why that is exactly.
I don't know.
I think it has something to do with the
fact that were self conscious,
but it's an existential reality rather
than a,
an indication of the pathology of a
given cultural construction.
You know that,
that's one of the reasons I really
liked,
well,
Heidi groove in part,
but the existentialist in general,
they just throw that out in front of you
and say,
look,
yes,
of course you have those problems.
Like that's it's always been that way.
The ancient Egyptians had a god that
represented the corrupting,
their corrupt,
the corruption of the state,
and the corrupting influence that
produced that corruption that was set
and set is the set,
the word sad eventually becomes the word
Satan.
I mean,
we've known this,
the Mesopotamians knew this.
They had a god king knew who was the
king of the monsters out of whose blood
to human beings were made.
It's like the idea that we're alienated
from what we create.
It's like,
yeah,
right.
Absolutely.
That's true.
So get up and do something about it.
You know,
it's,
it's not like you're unique in your
subjugation to the pathology of culture.
And it's also not the case that culture
is only pathological.
That's the other thing that's so that's
so disturbing.
I mean,
you have glasses on,
that's a good thing.
You don't bump into walls,
you know,
and so,
and that's a cultural artifact,
you know,
and I'd be dead six times over if it
wasn't for various medical
interventions.
And so,
you know,
leaving the fact that you're oppressed
with a little bit of gratitude is a
really wonderful thing.
And one of the things that just staggers
me about the,
the radical fringe that's,
that's,
that's characterized by these ideas that
we discussed tonight.
They have absolutely no gratitude for
anything.
And that's really something remarkable.
You know what it needs to say human
being is intolerable unless he has two
things.
Cleanliness and gratitude.
Well,
maybe they manage the first count,
although not always,
but they certainly do.
Sorry about that.
But they certainly don't manage this
second.
So
Yup.
You bring up article written
in the day,
the car note papers published this
morning,
a letter to the editor by a farm of the
student government,
the legislative affairs committee,
um,
in which they make several clams,
which I think you could use.
And what struck me as an attempt to
slander you,
things that happened with the
[inaudible] team building,
things like that.
But they make the assertion that you,
uh,
essentially abuse or hide behind the
banner or free speech in order to be
safe or to allow ourselves
to not adopt the ideas thrown out.
But I think this could be extended to
all types of speech in which the radical
lessons,
I wouldn't say I'm hiding behind the
banner of free speech.
Precisely.
So that would be the first error in
that.
I don't think that you can characterize
what I'm doing is hiding.
It isn't,
it isn't exactly,
it isn't exactly self evident that um,
the right to free speech has protected
me.
I would say a certain amount of good
fortune,
a certain amount of caution with my
words and a tremendous amount of public
support is what's protected me.
Um,
I also think that the ideological types
who pen those pieces of nonsense have,
have a common,
what a constant theme is.
Anyone who disagrees with them is
pathological in some manner and uses the
right of free speech to exercise that
pathology.
Well,
you know,
no,
that's just,
that's,
sorry,
that's not the case.
It's not the case.
And you know,
most of what's been leveled at me in
terms of slurs are they're low
resolution and ill informed.
You know,
I'm a trans fold by,
I'm a bigot.
What else?
I'm a racist.
I'm a Nazi.
That's a good one.
I'd been teaching about Nazi-ism for 30
years,
you know,
trying to tell people that they probably
would have been Nazi's had they been in
Germany during the 1930s,
which is at actually trying to convince
them of that,
which is something that you might need a
trigger warning for before you entered
the class.
You know,
so it's,
it's,
it's palpably absurd,
but it doesn't matter because if the war
of ideas is about power,
it doesn't matter whether you represent
either side with any degree of accuracy,
it's just part of the hobbsy in
nightmare.
And you know,
whoever spins the best story wins.
So yeah.
Anyways,
I've been weirdly fortunate because
every time the radicals have come after
me and they really came after me last
October,
um,
it's reversed every single time.
So,
and I'm not counting on that to
continue,
but it's been rather blackley comical as
it's been occurring.
So these articles,
it's like,
as far as I'm concerned,
they're a dime a dozen.
I don't even have to read them anymore.
That's the thing about reading
something,
an ideolog rights.
You just have to look at the first
sentence and infer the rest.
You know it's true,
man.
It's actually,
this is one of the things that
Solzhenitsyn did a brilliant job of
analyzing in the Gulag archipelago.
He said,
that's the consequence of turning your
God given sole over to human dogma.
You're just a puppet for these ideas
that are operating behind the scenes.
You think you have the ideas.
It's like think again.
They have you and they're doing with you
what the idea is want to have done with
you.
And when they're done with you,
they'll discard you.
You can be sure,
and you'll be lucky if there's anything
left of you when that happens.
So,
and the universities are absolutely
complicit in this.
They take young people whose minds are,
are,
who are looking for an identity and no
wonder,
and they teach them this algorithmic
idiocy that anyone with any brain could
learn in a week that that dictums and
dogma of the oppression versus,
oh,
pressed narrative,
God,
it's unbelievable.
You know,
a decent chat Bot could write most of
the postmodern papers.
That's why,
that's why they,
that's why the typical humanities,
80% of humanities papers now garner zero
citations,
which means the only person who ever
reads them as the person who wrote them
and even they don't do a very good job
of reading them.
So
yeah.
Well,
for starters now I feel terrible for
writing that article.
[inaudible]
no written with others and I would have
hoped it would have come across as more
of a thoughtful critique.
Are you,
are you actually serious?
Well,
I'm sorry,
I was a little hard on you.
I would say I'm more hard on your
professors,
so
it's fun in a glutton for punishment,
but anyway,
it's very brave of you to be standing
there by way
more about identity.
Really what you see then in the sense of
thrown this is it's a consequence of
human nature.
Human nature creates higher fees and
higher who's exclude or groups exclude
necessary to sort.
But what we see with a lot of the
sorting is that it's arbitrary and that
it's not the arbitrariness of nature,
but rather the arbitrary of structures
of society.
Like maybe nature lends itself to the
creation of arbitrary structures within
society.
I think that's fair.
Then people self identify with these
categories and these categories maybe
outdated or based on old understanding.
These are ultimately lead to greater
estrangement.
So the question is how do people
reckon with the parts of their identity
that may or may not contribute
to environments where people feel more
estranged,
more alone.
That's why you get educated is to
separate the wheat from the chaff.
You know,
because you're a historical creature,
right?
I mean,
it's outside of you and inside of you
and some of it's dead and corrupt,
as you just said,
and his strangers for no reason,
no,
no functional reason counter
productively,
but until you can,
until you understand the structures,
for better or for worse,
you're in no position to to do anything
but make them more fundamentally.
The purpose of a liberal education is
not to turn you into an Avatar of
capitalism or or,
or of or of democracy for that matter.
The purpose of a liberal education is to
enable you to comprehend the history in
which you're embedded and then to act as
an agent to,
to reconstruct and revitalize that
hierarchy.
But that's a serious matter like at 18
say,
and right out of high school with no
experience whatsoever in life and no
real education.
You're in absolutely no position
whatsoever to be protesting about the
structure of the Western world.
It's like,
no,
sorry.
You know your,
your observations about the fact that
people are alienated by structures like
absolutely.
Of course.
And it does sort and it sorts harshly.
And of course,
because you're young,
you tend to be sorted near the bottom.
Except that I would point out that
you're young and there's really
something to that.
You know,
and you might think that you have no
power because of that.
But I could say,
well,
you have all the power that youth gives
you and that's not trivial.
So where power doesn't lie,
where it's obvious,
you know,
it really doesn't.
And people have more power than they
think,
but they squander it.
And he often squandered on ideology when
they're not just wasting their time.
So
anyways,
it was very brave of you to stand up and
ask me a question and to take all of
that criticism.
[inaudible]
none or religious,
the phrase the carefully positioned in
the diagnostic atheism,
there is no literal gun in the objective
universe or at least no gut humans would
be interested in is intellectually hard
of a sale.
Still there's good evidence for
religious behavior,
has an advantage produced by natural
selection.
Do you think that self critically acting
in a way as if God exists is efficient
to leverage evolutionary wisdom or it
must have religions,
articles of faith,
people,
Lehman defendant in the same manner as
literal facts?
That's a good question.
One of the things that I read when I was
reading Karl,
Yo,
he made this claim,
which I really liked was that whatever
sits atop of your pinnacle of value is
functionally equivalent to God.
That's good.
That's really smart.
Um,
and I like it smarter than it sounds,
which is the case with most of the
things that you wrote because it
actually does turn out that our category
systems are not so much about
subdividing the material world into it's
appropriate entities,
but about carving up our experience into
categories of tools and obstacles so
that we can attain certain valued goals.
And so we're always directing our action
towards the attainment of a goal.
And so that means we're immersed in a
value structure.
And so young's point was whatever sits
at the pinnacle of your value structure
serves the function of God.
Now you might have a fragmented value
structure,
which means in some sense that you're
psychologically polytheistic.
And the problem with that is that then
you're a house divided amongst itself.
You're pulling in multiple directions
simultaneously.
Impulsive people are like that,
right?
And they don't understand themselves
because one day they go left and the
other day they go right.
And you know,
they,
they have no control over themselves at
all.
Now you said,
well,
there's no objective God,
and that seems to be a reasonable
hypothesis.
Um,
the question then I suppose becomes to
what degree our subjective experience is
real.
And that's a matter of definition.
Um,
I think the religious impulse is an
inevitable consequence of the fact that
it's necessary for people to live inside
hierarchies of value and that we feel a
sense of awe.
The sense of all we feel with regards to
the highest values is no not
distinguishable from the existence of
the value itself now.
And there's real advantages to the idea
of a detached God in some sense.
And one of the things I've learned about
archaic concepts of sovereignty is that,
um,
detaching the idea of ethical of ethics
itself and ethical power from the holder
of power is an extraordinarily useful
thing to do because otherwise the cane
becomes the embodiment of the God.
And then the king can do no wrong.
Then you have a tyrant.
If the idea of power and sovereignty is
detached from the individual and set up
as a higher virtue that even the
sovereign is,
is uh,
responsible to them.
The sovereign,
at least in principle,
can never put,
put himself forward as absolute.
And you can think about that just as a
development of humans' capacity to
abstract,
right?
We can abstract the idea of sovereignty,
we can abstract the idea of ethics and
virtue.
We can,
we can hypothesize that as an ideal,
we can embody it as a personality,
which is actually quite useful because
it's something we have to act out.
Now you might say,
well,
what relationship does that have to,
you know,
to the existence of,
of something transcendent in the
religious sense outside of that abstract
conceptualization.
And the answer to that is we don't know
if you,
if you familiarize yourself with the
writings of people who've had profound
religious experiences,
it's chronically the case that they
described encountering something that
transcends and that they describe it as
more real than anything they've ever
encountered.
Now,
whether or not that constitutes proof,
depends on how you define proof.
So I'm not making a case for it one way
or another,
but I mean young himself,
I mean when he talked about God,
when he was being careful,
he didn't talk about God.
He talked about the God image in man and
he was careful never to formally state
that the fact that there's an image of
the ideal in the soul,
let's say an archetype that that
provided concrete proof that such an
ideal existed,
you know,
in some transcendent manner.
But the world's a weird place and it's
not something I would rule out.
So it's not like we understand the world
very well.
And materialists,
you know,
they try to,
yeah,
they tried to encapsulate the entire
world within the materialist philosophy
and like more power to them.
It's been an unbelievably successful
tool,
but we haven't cracked consciousness in
the least.
And there is something about
consciousness that's world creating and
there's something transcendent about
consciousness and it also seems capable
of a kind of infinite expansion.
And it isn't obvious why any of that is
the case.
Not obvious at all.
So,
okay.
Yup.
Hello?
Okay.
So,
um,
okay.
Okay.
Before they were writing this stuff up
for World War II was a critical theorist
criticizing Marxism itself and the
student
radicals in
Harvard,
mark up on the deck.
So those ideas seem to get bryce
section,
you don't really see eye to eye with how
smarter
objective realities.
So I mean what do you make of that?
People can,
we have tactic reality but the truth is
health and like they need like rebel
against the majority to express their
own throat.
Well,
okay,
so two things.
I mean there's been a number of attempts
to revise Marx's theory,
right?
And so you pointed to one that's the
cultural theorists and that was after
World War II when it became painfully
obvious at least to the first round of
people who were oriented towards the
radical left but opened the rise that
there was something rotten in the state
of the Soviet Union.
And so they did a,
they did their best to revamped the
central doctrines of Marxism using
[inaudible] and theory and so forth.
And yeah,
as you said,
they were very influential among the
student radicals of the 60s and it was
them that gave birth to the modern crop
of say,
postmodern Neo Marxists.
I think that,
you know,
I couldn't cover all of that obviously
in one lecture,
but your,
your point is well taken.
Um,
now you had,
you ended that with a different
question.
So,
but I don't remember exactly what that
question was.
Oh,
there's just,
people will track the benefit.
Oh yes.
Well look,
I mean look,
the ultimate minority is the individual
and the individual always stands in
opposition with his or her truth to that
of the mob.
So that's true is that it's very
frequently the case that truth is held
by something outside the general
consensus.
Now false hood is too,
right?
So I mean if you,
if you have a structure that's
reasonably functional,
new,
like a little walled city,
and you've got a hundred people outside
yelling about how pathological it is,
99 of them would make it worse.
And one of them has something useful to
say.
And so you can't just dispense with the
minority,
so to speak,
because the majority of the minority is
going to be wrong in their opposition
because the one person in the minority
who isn't wrong is absolutely vital.
And that's the tension.
That's always the tension between the
group.
That's partly the mythological hero
really has two roles.
One is to go out and conquer the dragon
of darkness and to gather information
and to disseminate it.
But the second rule,
which is equally important,
is to stand up against the corrupt
culture,
which is what horace does.
For example,
in the ancient Egyptian stories,
demolish what's,
what's corrupt and then rebuild
something and it's in,
it's in.
It's uh,
what in the aftermath you do that
psychologically too.
You know,
because you have an interpretive
structure through which you view the
world and now,
and then you run into something that's
like a minority,
a fact that doesn't fit and but it's,
but it's actually a fact that it
indicates that part of you needs to die
and
encounter chaos and reconstitute
yourself.
And that's why there is this dynamism
between the group and the individual and
also why the individual is held in the
west to be a power,
let's say that superordinate to the
state.
The state has to recognize the validity
of the individual because the individual
does,
in the final analysis,
hold the redemptive truth.
But to put that in minority groups,
that's a whole different issue.
That's a slight of hand as far as I'm
concerned,
so.
All right.
Well,
thank you.
[inaudible].